About an hour ago, Donald Trump
addressed the American people. This
follows an address
from
Prime Minister Albanese of Australia to
his people as well as Prime Minister
Starmer to the British people.
And in both speeches by Starmer and
Albanese, they said they said to the to
the people, "We know that fuel prices,
gas prices are going up
and we should expect more pain, but we
will do as much as we can to to ensure
that your
wallet is not too impacted."
Donald Trump in his address to the
American people basically said that
this war will continue
and
America may start to bomb energy and oil
infrastructure of Iran. Okay, so let's
listen to a few of his words.
Our economy is strong and improving by
the day, and it will soon be roaring
back like never before. It will top the
levels that it was a month ago.
I made clear from the beginning of
Operation Epic Fury that we will
continue until our objectives are fully
achieved.
Thanks to the progress we've made, I can
say tonight that we are on track to
complete all of America's military
objectives shortly, very shortly.
We're going to hit them extremely hard
over the next two to three weeks. We're
going to bring them back to the Stone
Ages where they belong.
Okay, so he's basically saying that
we're winning this war
and where we will bomb them to Stone
Ages, which tells us
he's actually not winning this war,
okay? Now,
um um
I also want to look at another
um
person who is Peter Hoekstra. New
strategic map.
So, remember, this war in Iran, it's not
ending. In fact, many people believe
it's only starting to ramp up. So, there
are rumors that Donald Trump has has
already authorized the use of ground
forces.
And so, we could see an invasion of Iran
as early as this weekend. But,
certainly, definitely,
um this month, okay? But, while America
is fighting this war in Iran,
this is the second of war Peter
Hoekstra, and he's announced that
America will control all North America.
From Greenland to the Gulf of America to
the Panama Canal and its surrounding
countries.
At the Department of War, we call this
strategic map the greater North America.
Why?
Because every sovereign nation and
territory north of the equator, from
Greenland to Ecuador and from Alaska to
Guyana, is not part of the
global south.
It's the
security perimeter in this great
neighborhood that we all live in.
Okay.
So, basically,
what he's saying is we will enforce the
Monroe Doctrine in North America. So, it
sounds very strange to people in that
Donald Trump is fighting this war in
Iran that's not really winnable. The
same time,
he is uh being aggressive in North
America. He's seeking fights with
Canada, with Denmark over Greenland,
with Colombia, with Mexico, with Cuba.
In fact, he's embargoing embargoing Cuba
right now and people expect possibly an
invasion of Cuba very soon. So, people
just think that Donald Trump is all over
place and he's idiotic, okay? So, this
is Iran and everyone says that a ground
invasion of Iran would be stupid because
it is much too large to invade. Right
now, America America has only about
50,000 troops in the Middle East and the
geography, the terrain makes it very
hard to control, okay? So, you have
these mountains, the Zagros Mountains,
which allows for the Iranians to hide
and conduct guerrilla warfare and use
drone strikes and artillery strikes.
Um and then you have the desert, which
make which makes it very hard to cross,
okay? So, even if the Americans were to
attack from here, from Iraq,
um they would have to face the
mountains. If they were to attack from
Pakistan, from the east, they would have
to face deserts, okay?
And [snorts] if they were to attack from
the south, they would face all these
mountains and also you're far away from
Tehran, which is ultimately your your
objective.
Okay? So, there are there's lots of
conversations about what the Americans
are trying to do. Right now, the
consensus seems to be the Americans
first want to control the Strait of
Hormuz in order to elevate the strain on
the global economy, okay? But as you can
see from this map, first of all, the
strait it's not very wide and it's very
close to the Iranian coastline and the
mountains, so it's easy to attack from
and
um
there are these and then the Iranians
can put mines all around the strait as
well. So, what everyone tells us is that
an invasion of Iran would just be
idiotic. But, at the same time, the
Americans need to free up the Strait of
Hormuz and allow for maritime navigation
in order to stabilize the global
economy. Okay?
Um already we're seeing lots of signs
that America's preparing for a long,
long war. So, there are already 50,000
troops in the Middle East, and a lot of
them are will be uh deployed against
Iran. But, also there's a letter from
Leonard Anderson to reserves telling
them to to to say telling them
"We must get ready to deploy, fight, and
win."
Okay? So, not only have they sent 50,000
troops to Middle East, but they're
preparing to call up the reserves as
well. Okay? So, this seems as though
America's preparing for total war.
Uh PredictIt is a very interesting place
to understand how global events will
turn out, okay? And so, there are three
indicators that in fact a war is coming,
a ground invasion is coming. First of
all, the peace pizza index is exploding.
What does this mean? It means that in
the Pentagon,
um when they're preparing to launch a
ground invasion, they need to work
overtime. And so, they call for pizza.
Okay?
Uh and and so, pizza deliveries are
going up. Gay bars
are empty. Okay? So, when people are,
you know, don't have much to do, they go
and you know, go on dates. The last is
that
people are making bets,
large bets that a ground invasion will
happen, okay? So, these are people
people who have inside information.
And so, they go on PredictIt and make
make a bet that this will happen,
knowing it will happen. So, this guy bet
$200,000 that an a ground invasion will
happen, and if it turns out an a ground
invasion does happen, he will win over a
million dollars. Okay? So, these are
three very good indicators that a ground
invasion has been approved, and it will
happen very, very soon.
Okay. Um Donald Trump himself
has said many, many things, okay? So,
he said that, "You know what? If we
leave the Middle East, it's not our
problem. We don't really care, okay?"
And he also says that,
"Hey, NATO,
it's your responsibility to open the
Strait of Hormuz because we told you so,
and because you need the oil."
And of course, NATO is angry at Donald
Trump because previously, Donald Trump
threatened to take over Greenland.
Okay? So, everything's Donald Trump says
is a He doesn't plan ahead
because before this war in Iran, it
where he needs the help of NATO, he was
pissing off NATO by threatening over
Greenland. So, Donald Trump is all over
the place. He's just a right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um but
let's just
assume, okay,
that the ground invasion goes ahead.
What will happen? Well, as I as I
predicted before, if a ground invasion
were to go ahead, first of all, America
would lose this war because a ground
invasion would fail, and Iranians are
fully prepared for ground invasion.
Second of all, if America loses war, the
American empire would die because we're
forced out of the Middle East. They will
they will lose the petrodollar and the
US dollar as a global reserve currency.
The third thing is the global economy
would collapse.
So, clearly Donald Trump is the worst
president in human history.
And he's a complete buffoon.
Right?
Okay.
But, let's put our thinking caps on.
Okay, let's use game theory and say
but
what if
for some strange reason Donald Trump
wants to lose his war in Iran?
What if he wants the American empire to
collapse?
What if
Donald Trump wants to destroy the global
economy?
Then he'd be a genius, right?
Right?
He's a because he's going to
destroy the American empire, but if he
actually wants to destroy the American
empire, then the man is
the greatest American president ever,
okay?
Okay, so we're going to have a fun
discussion today, and we're going to
make the argument that in fact Donald
Trump is a genius. That in fact all this
chaos
um is purposeful.
That there's actually a plan behind all
this, okay? That's the argument I want
to make to you
uh today. Okay.
So, what is the plan? What is going on
here? All right, so first thing to
notice is that the world gets 20%
Okay? 20%
of its
oil from
the Middle East, okay? Primarily going
to
um
East Asia. So, India gets about 6% of
its oil from the Middle East. Japan gets
6.75% of its oil from the Middle East.
So, East Asia is heavily dependent on
Middle East oil, okay? But, as you can
see, it also goes to Europe as well. And
then also to the United States.
All right, so the world is dependent on
the
GCC oil. If this war continues, if
ground forces are used, then all the oil
from the Middle East collapses, and JP
Morgan has come out and said that by
mid-April, the world will run out of
oil.
Okay? So, this is a disaster for the
world.
But it's not It's just much more than
energy needs, okay? So, this
by because Iran is constraining movement
in the Strait of Hormuz, we're seeing
we're seeing seven major
uh shortages.
Okay? So, yes, we know oil and LNG are
um
are being stopped, okay? But actually,
the problem is much worse because look
at phosphate,
ammonium, [snorts]
sulfur, urea.
This is food production.
Okay? Primarily used for fertilizers.
In other words, if this war
persists,
not only will countries run out of
energy, they'll also run out of food.
Okay?
Also, look at this.
Helium
and sulfur are used for what? They're
used for
um semiconductors, the production of
semiconductors. Used um
um helium and sulfuric acid in the
production of semiconductors, which
leads to AI, okay?
So, in other words, this
s- um
war in the Middle East, it's it's
impacting everything in the modern
economy.
Okay? It's If this war continues, the
global economy could collapse.
But again, we're we're making the
assumption that Donald Trump is a genius
and this is all part of his big plan,
okay? So, what is his plan?
All right.
So,
okay, we know that there's a lot of oil
in the
Middle East.
Okay?
But, you know, oil is not as rare as
people think it is. There's also a lot
of oil in
Canada.
Venezuela has
the world's
um largest oil reserves,
okay?
Uh Russia also has a lot of oil.
So, in other words,
if
the Strait of Hormuz is closed, if this
war in the GCC continues,
it doesn't mean the world no longer has
oil. It all it means is the world is now
much more dependent on
North America
and Russia
for
oil.
And so, the global economy now shifts
over to North America and to Russia.
Okay? So, in other words, the United
States starts a stupid war
in the GCC in the Middle East it can't
possibly win, but it still benefits.
Because now the world is much more
dependent on North America. Okay? Why is
Venezuela important? Because America
just took over Venezuela in January.
Okay? And that And look And look, Canada
has a lot of oil and Trump is
threatening to take over
Canada.
Okay? So,
now let's look Let's look at who needs
the oil.
Well,
this map tells you that if you're in the
red, you you consume more oil than you
export. And who are these countries?
Well, they're Europe.
Okay?
And they are East Asia.
As well as Australia.
Okay?
So, yes, I understand Donald Trump's an
idiot. Yes, I understand that he's going
to lose this war in the Middle East.
Yes, I understand he's going to destroy
the world economy,
but for some strange reason, he
benefits. The United States benefits
because now Europe and China,
Japan, Australia, they're much more
dependent on North America for
resources, for food, for energy.
Okay?
All right, food. Okay, so nitrogen is
important for fertilizers. Okay? You
need nitrogen for fertilizers. Um and as
you can and what this map tells you is
that if you are in the blue or the light
blue, it means you produce more nitrogen
than you need, so you export it. If you
are not in the blue, then you're kind of
screwed, okay? So, basically,
this area, this area especially,
uh this area. Okay?
Uh Europe as some parts parts of Europe,
okay?
So, now they need more nitrogen. And
again, before they were getting a lot of
nitrogen, ammonia, from the Middle East.
And now, where do where they forced to
get the nitrogen?
From here
and from here.
Okay?
So, again,
yes, I know Donald Trump's losing this
war in the Middle East.
But in the long term, America stands to
benefit.
>> [snorts]
>> Right.
Lastly, lastly I want to look at is
water, okay? Water is important because
water tells us which areas are the most
stable. Basically, if you have a if you
have a lot of water, you are less prone
to conflict.
But if you don't have that much water,
then you're prone to conflict, okay? So
we looked at we look at So if you're in
a
dark blue, you're good, okay? Nothing to
worry about. If you are in the light
blue, you are in a lot of trouble, okay?
So if we look at this area, North
America, pretty stable because lots and
lots of fresh water, okay? If you look
at Russia, pretty stable, lots and lots
of
um
uh fresh water. But if you're Africa,
you're in a lot of trouble. If you're
Europe, you're in a lot of trouble. If
you are Middle East, you're in a lot of
trouble. If you are um
Southeast Asia,
uh
you
are not not much trouble, but you are in
some trouble, okay?
So or we we already see how this map
tells us where
in the future, basically Russia and the
United States, North America,
are the most stable parts of the world
with the most resources. And therefore,
they are the most resilient, the most
stable, okay?
But if you go to Africa,
Europe, Middle East, Southeast Asia,
these are points of
conflict in the world. So we we can
expect these places to become much more
unstable over time.
So in other words, all the United States
and Russia have have to do is maintain
stability and then export resources to
these places. And guess what?
If they And then they make a lot of
money for themselves.
Okay? So, again, I understand Donald
Trump's an idiot. I understand this war
in the Middle East is stupid, but from a
long-term game theory perspective,
the United States wins from this
disaster from a long-term perspective,
okay?
Now,
you look at this map and think, "Well,
China's pretty good, too, right?" Like,
China has a lot of fresh water. The
problem with with China, though, is
this.
China
sits on a lot of fresh water that
Southeast Asia and India depends on,
okay? So, a lot of water
is in the Tibetan Plateau, and it flows
downstream
into India and in Southeast Asia. If
there were drought,
using game theory, we can suspect that
China might want to
keep the water for itself, right? In
which case,
Southeast Asia and India would be very
angry, okay? So, this is a potential
flash point
>> [snorts]
>> that we have to watch out for.
Okay? So, it seems like China is stable,
but
the surrounding areas are not so stable,
and so China will be dragged into a
conflict.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
So, let's summarize what we've learned
so far. So, these are the countries with
the most oil reserves, okay? Venezuela,
uh Saudi Arabia,
Iran, Canada, Iraq, UAE, Kuwait, United
States, Russia.
Uh okay. All right. Now, what's
interesting about this is this.
This war in the Middle East is going to
knock out the oil production of Saudi
Arabia,
of Iran, of Iraq, of UAE, of Kuwait.
Which leaves what? Which leaves Uh-oh,
Venezuela, Canada,
and the United States, okay? North
America.
And Russia.
Okay?
Now, then look Let's look at Let's look
at who has to buy oil. All right? Look
Look at who who buys oil.
Well,
the United States consumes a lot oil,
but again, it has its own supply of oil.
China needs to import a lot its oil
needs, okay? So, China needs to import
75% of its
um
uh oil needs. India,
Russia, Saudi Arabia, Brazil, Japan,
South Korea, okay?
Um Germany.
All right. So, China,
India,
Japan, South Korea import a lot of oil.
And where does it get its oil from? The
Middle East, right? So, if it can't get
its oil from the Middle East, then these
four countries, China, India, Japan, and
South Korea will need to get to get the
oil either from the United States or
Russia.
Okay? And why does this matter? Well,
well, look look Look Look at this.
Look at who owns
the most US Treasuries.
Basically, if you want to buy a lot of
US Treasuries, it means that you are
financing American debt. America right
now is is $39 trillion in debt. That's a
lot of money,
but as long as people continue buy US
debt,
as long as people want to buy US
Treasuries, it's not a problem, okay?
It's a Ponzi scheme.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
So, let's look at this. Who are the
biggest um
holders of US debt? Japan, China,
right?
Um
Taiwan, Singapore, Hong Kong, India.
Okay, so this is all Asia.
And we already said
that Asia needs a lot of oil from the
Middle East,
right? Now, look look look at
uh
others. United Kingdom is second, okay?
Cayman Islands is basically just Eu-
Europe as well. It's um
it's a money la- money operation, okay?
Belgium, Luxembourg, Fra- Canada,
France, Ireland, Switzerland.
These countries are Europe.
And again,
where did we say
most oil from the GCC go? It goes to
either E- Asia or Europe.
And now because of war in the Middle
East, Asia and Europe are now forced by
oil from either Russia or the United
States.
And this is important, okay? This is
important because previously, there's a
fear that these countries would stop
buying US Treasuries because America is
too heavily in debt. The American
American economy is too much of a Ponzi
scheme. So, there's this great fear that
Europe and Asia would
would move away from the US dollar and
more towards Swiss francs or gold, okay?
Now,
because Europe and Asia need fertilizer,
they need energy from the United States
and North America,
the United States no longer has to worry
about its debt, okay?
All right? The $39 trillion debt? Not a
problem because the entire world is
dependent on North America for
resources.
The policy can keep on going.
So again, Donald Trump is an idiot.
But he's so stupid, he's become a
genius.
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
Now, you're like, "Wait, but Donald
Trump's an idiot. Where would he get
this Where would he get this idea from?
How do you know how to do this?"
And the answer is because Putin has
already proven that this strategy works
in Ukraine. Okay? So let me show you
how. Okay. So this is the war in
Ukraine.
And as you can see,
um the dark red are areas in which
Russia is contesting territory.
>> [snorts]
>> The light red, uh sorry, the pink are
areas
in which
Russia wants to gain territory.
As you can see, Russia still has a long
way to go. And we're we're already 4 5
years into this war.
Which means that this war can go on for
another 10 20 years. It's a very slow
grind.
And
it's good for Russia. Yes, I know that
Russia is losing a lot of soldiers.
And I know that the Russian economy is
suffering, but this long war of
attrition is good for Russia. Why? Well,
because first of all, what it does is
>> [snorts]
>> it allows Russia
to industrialize its economy.
Okay? It allows its
uh it allows Russia to center its
economy around war production, okay? So
the red, um as you can see,
is total
industry.
Okay? And as you can see, it's been
going up since the war started.
All right? Overall industry has been
going up as as well.
Unfortunately, industries that are not
dominated by the military, that have no
war purpose, is actually going down.
Okay?
So, it seems as though the entire
Russian economy is being restructured
for total war, for a long war. And that
is the purpose. That is the goal.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. So, again, the pink
are
um military industries. The blue are
civilian industries. And as you can see,
the blue Sorry, the
um
pink completely dominate the blue.
And the trend is increasing. Meaning it
is possible in four, five years time
Russia's primarily a war economy.
Industrializing
to produce war weapons, okay?
Ammunitions.
Uh specifically
drones, okay?
These are drones.
All right.
So,
um
before at the be- at the at beginning of
the war,
Russia was dependent on Iran for drones,
okay?
But then, what happened over time is
that
um Russia
started to
have its own domestic production, okay?
So, imports from Iran have stayed
constant.
And then, domestic production has gone
way up. Which tells us that the Russian
economy is industrializing
for the production of drones.
And Russia is preparing to fight a long,
long war.
Now, not only
can Russia produce its own drones for
the war, but it can also
export its drones to Iran to fight
against the Americans.
Okay?
And so you're like, "Wait a minute here.
So,
Russia is switching its entire economy
to war production, which means that
Russia
will always fight wars."
Is that what Russia's planning? And the
answer is, yes, it is, okay? And so let
let let me explain why Russia is
planning this.
This is one called the Third Rome plan,
okay? And this comes from the 1996 book,
sorry, 1996 book,
Foundations of Geopolitics, okay? By
Alexander Dugin, who I think is one of
the smartest
geopolitical
thinkers alive today, okay? And his
argument is this. His argument is,
"This unipolar moment of American
dominance,
>> [snorts]
>> um it's going to fade away because it's
too much focus on secularism,
individualism, liberalism, and these
ideas break apart community.
These ideas are anti-human. So,
eventually, Western society, Western
civilization, will collapse because its
values are abhorrent.
And when it collapses, this this is this
is opportunity for Moscow to become the
Third Rome, okay?"
Uh we'll talk more about this in the
future.
But what's brilliant about Dugin is he
recognizes that when the world
collapses, all Russia has to do is stay
stable and resilient.
As long as it stays together, unified,
cohesive, it'll be fine.
Okay? Because as this global order
collapses, as the global economy
collapses, every other society will face
eternal collapse, such as the United
States, okay? So, he he predicts civil
war
in the United States as left and right
go to war against each other.
Okay? He predicts
uh collapse of China. He predicts
collapse of
um
the Middle East. He predicts collapse of
Europe, okay? So, all these places are
collapsing. Basically, if you are the
main pillar of the global economy, you
are much more susceptible to collapse
than if you are not, okay? What What So,
what Dugin says is this, okay? All
right.
So, the strategy is, first of all,
Russia needs to stay coherent. It needs
to defend its territory.
It needs to unify its people through
nationalism, through religion, through
faith.
And then what Russia needs to do is
figure out allies
that it that would support the Russian
outlook. And this And these allies could
include Japan.
Okay?
Uh Vietnam, India, Iran.
Okay? And then, by combining their
forces,
they become a trading block onto
themselves. This is an age of nuclear
weapons. You don't want to go to war
against each other.
But this is also an age of collapse. So,
as long as you're able to stay coherent,
as long as you're able to defend your
borders,
then you'll come out ahead, okay?
So, that's the idea of moving towards
war, because war has a power to unify
the imagination and the beliefs of the
people in your nation.
All right? So, using war in order to
increase the nationalism, the religion
of your society, which will allow you to
weather the storm better, okay? So, that
is the grand vision of Alexander Dugin,
and in my opinion, he's absolutely
correct. And Russia is moving towards
this by invading Ukraine, all right? So,
the Ukraine invasion was not a response
to NATO. The Ukraine invasion was to
implement this grand vision for the
creation of the Third Rome, to allow
Russia to survive the coming collapse of
the global order
better than anyone else, okay?
And so, by taking over Ukraine,
you now control 1/3 of the world's
carbohydrates and a lot of the world's
energy,
right? Once you can control Ukraine and
the Black Sea, you are now able to
export your energy and your food to
Africa, to the Middle East, to Europe,
to Asia, okay?
So, that's the grand vision for Russia.
And again, in my opinion, this makes a
lot of sense. The world is collapsing,
and so you have to
um build a fortress.
You have to be self-sufficient in order
to weather the storm.
So, given this, America's like, "Well,
we can do the same thing, okay?" And so,
the grand plan for America is something
called
the Technate, okay?
Sorry.
It's something we'll discuss more later
on, okay? But first I I first I I want
to introduce this this idea to you, the
Technate.
And the Technate is very simple. It's
the idea that, "You know what? Yes, the
world is going into chaos.
The world is collapsing.
But, uh North America is
self-sufficient.
Right? So, these past few months, Donald
Trump has been has been picking picking
a fight with uh Denmark over Greenland,
right?
He's been threatening Canada.
He's been threatening Mexico. He's been
threatening
uh Colombia. He's He's thinking over
Venezuela. He's been uh threatening
Cuba. He's been threatening Honduras,
Nicaragua. Why is he doing this? Cuz
they're all part
of the grand vision for greater North
America. Okay, what Peter Zeihan calls
greater North America.
The Technate.
All right? And this is a response to
Moscow's Third Rome. If Moscow is going
to build this grand alliance
in order to weather the storm, America
has no choice but to also build this
grand alliance as well in order to
protect itself in this coming storm.
All right? So, what Donald Trump has
recognized is that Putin is right. The
world is collapsing. There's nothing we
can do to save the world.
So, let's just accelerate it in a way
that allows America to benefit from this
collapse.
Okay? So, by collapsing the GCC, by
collapsing the Middle East,
you make Asia and Europe now dependent
on American
um North American energy and fertilizer
exports.
And this allows you the resources, the
motivation to create the Technate.
Okay? This self-sufficient
um economy. Okay?
Does it make sense?
All right? Okay.
All right.
So, let us summarize. Okay. So, in
um
November sorry, September 11th, 1991,
George H.W. Bush
he responds to the fall of the Berlin
Wall, the collapse of of Soviet by
calling new phrase called the new world
order.
And there are three major pillars to the
idea of the new world order, okay? The
first idea is that America will become
the financial capital of the world. We
America will offshore
uh resources and manufacturing to other
places.
And then America will focus primarily on
finance, making Wall Street
the center of the world, okay?
The other idea is the idea of secular
multiculturalism. So, the world is
divided, but what can unite everyone is
the love of money, the love of
consumerism.
So, if we just focus on making money and
buying things, then the world will be
forever at peace.
Okay?
And so, we have to let go of
borders. We have to let go of community.
We have to let go of identity and focus
more on consumerism, okay? And the And
the last idea is
global domination,
where in order for global trade to
happen,
America will provide security for all.
No one has to fight anymore because
America will guarantee global peace. If
anyone rises to challenge this order,
Pax Americana, then America will go
destroy it.
Okay?
So, these are the three main pillars
>> [snorts]
>> of the new world order as announced by
George H.W. Bush on September 11th, uh
1991, okay?
Trump world order is a response to this
new world order. Basically, what Trump
is saying and what what what he's been
saying for a long time is, "Why should
America pay for the defense of other
nations?
Why should America
have to be
uh the consumer of last resort for
everyone? Why are the American Why are
Americans paying for everything so that
Europeans can have their welfare and the
pension?
Everyone's taking advantage of America
and is destroying America. So, let us
change the new world order to the Trump
world order, okay? And how do you do
that? Well, you move America from a
focus on finance to a focus on resources
and manufacturing, okay? Basically, you
you believe the world is going to
permanent war and so you provide the
resources and the manufacturing in order
to facilitate this world war. Meanwhile,
America is has become fortress America.
It can It can hide behind its
um fortress kind of kind of no fortress
and it's protected by two oceans, right?
Okay? So, this makes sense.
Multiculturalism doesn't work. It leads
to stupidity such as DEI, woke politics,
trans-genderism. It's all
Let's focus on what makes us proud to be
Americans, which is Christian
nationalism, okay? Our love of the white
race, our nation, and God.
Okay? So, no more of this
multiculturalism. No more immigration.
No more open borders. No more Democratic
Party. Let's just focus on being
Christian nationalists, okay? Love the
United States, love of Christianity,
love of
um the white race.
And the last idea is, "Why should
America pay to protect the world? Screw
Pax Americana. Let's just do MAGA,
okay?" What is MAGA? MAGA is national
rejuvenation.
Let's make America great again by
rebuilding America's manufacturing
industry,
by exploiting the infinite resources
that God has given America in order to
make sure every American
um has a decent life, okay?
All right? So, again, I understand Trump
is an idiot. Trump has launched America
into this stupid war in the Middle East.
Trump has pissed off NATO. Trump has
pissed off all of America's allies.
So, he's a
But,
if the goal was to destroy the American
empire,
destroy the global economy, and rebuild
America for the benefit of Americans,
then Trump is a genius. And he may go
down in history as America's greatest
president.
Okay?
All right.
Um any questions?
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, so uh my first question is you
mentioned that what the the the Donald
Trump or like Putin, they they think
that the world, like the whole system,
will collapse inevitable, but like how
why? Like if this uh Ukraine war doesn't
happen or if this Iran war won't happen,
how will the world economy collapse?
Like Okay.
Okay, that's a really good question,
okay?
So, um
both Putin and Trump know that the world
will collapse. And the question is how
do they know this? And the answer is
because it's so obvious, okay?
So, um for the longest time
America
started,
um,
What America did was
it basically
um, after World War II
it
lent money to Europe and Japan so that
Europe and Japan can buy manufactured
goods from America, okay? And this is
good for America.
Um, because it created a lot of jobs.
And Americans were productive.
But then over time
Americans became very lazy. And so they
made the Europeans and the Japanese
do the work, especially Germany. And
then America started to
um,
be
the consumer, okay? So then America
started to spend more money than it
made, okay? Before it made more money
than it spent, and lent this money to
Europe and Japan. But then over time
this reversed itself.
Okay?
And then what happened was that America
started to shift its manufacturing to
China.
And so China is like, "Let's
let me do all the work for you, America.
And
um,
I'll do it for really cheaply, and I'll
borrow money from you. So sorry, sorry.
I'll I'll lend you money to do it, okay?
So what's happening is that America is
becoming lazy
in debt
and corrupt.
Okay? Because the entire world was
basically
um, working for America for very little
money. So America didn't really have to
work.
And this led to massive inequality
in America, which led to political
corruption.
Which led to an oligarchy, okay? So,
don't think of America as a
democracy, think of it as an oligarchy.
And so, when that happens, when only a
few people benefit from the system,
then the American people get really
pissed. And so, they affect they elected
for they elected Donald Trump, okay? And
why did Donald Trump get elected?
Because he understood intuitively this
system does not work. It cannot It
cannot
hold. It cannot be stable for too long.
It's going to collapse eventually, okay?
The question then is
when will collapse and who will benefit
from the collapse? And Donald Trump's
like, "Okay, then
let's control the collapse so that my
friends and I can benefit the most from
this collapse, okay?" And Donald Trump
has two sets of friends. The first are
are the Christians, okay?
Christian evangelicals, basically the
fanatics who support Israel, as well as
the AI, Silicon Valley.
All right? So, we learned about the idea
of elite overproduction, okay? But the
idea is that as a society collapses,
declines,
the elite start to compete against
themselves for resources.
And so, right now the elite are the
finance people.
And the new elite, okay, the counter
elites,
are the AI people, okay? Artificial
intelligence. And it's something we'll
discuss later on.
Okay, but I let introduce you to the
idea. But basically, the idea is that
America is a is a is a house of cards,
it's a Ponzi scheme, it's corrupt, it's
unequal, it's lazy, it's in decline. So,
it's So, it's going to fall apart sooner
or later,
okay?
But the question then is like, how do
you manage this decline? How do you
control this decline in a way that
allows you you and your friends to
benefit the most?
Okay? And that's why Donald Trump
started this war in the Middle East.
Because by starting this war in the
Middle East, you're accelerating the
process of decline in America, and
therefore, you're able to help transform
America from one of the from a from an
economy that's based on finance to one
that's based on resource exploitation
and in manufacturing.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right. Any more questions?
>> [snorts]
>> So, I have one last questions about the
explanations of this war. Like before we
explained it in the religious
perspectives, and how does this like
this explanation connect to the explain
explanation today?
Okay. All right. Yeah, that's a really
good question, okay? So, the thing to
understand about war is that there are
different factors at play, okay? So,
before we we went went into
eschatological
factor.
All right. Now, I'll explain explain to
you the geopolitical
or the um
um economic, okay? But, there's also the
historical.
Or hubris.
Right? And what you need what you need
need to recognize about history is that
often all three things converge
together, okay? Because what is
religion?
Religion is a memory a long lost memory
of our ancient past
told through myths and stories.
So, there's truth to religion because
it's basing a lot of its ideas
through personal experience through
history, okay? From thousands of years
ago.
Right? And geopolitics economics drives
historical forces. So, another way
another way of understanding this is
that often all these things are factors
are aligned together. We're going to
discuss more later on, okay?
Right? And so, why do I look at
different factors?
Different vectors. And the answer is
because I'm making predictions. And if
I'm able to analyze an event using
eschatology, geopolitics, and history,
and they align together, then I can make
a pretty accurate prediction that this
will happen.
I don't know when it will happen. I
mean, I don't know who know who the
players are, but I'm pretty sure this
event will happen.
Okay? Does it make sense?
Okay, great.
All right. So, uh we'll we'll continue
this next week, okay?